a very good evening well tonight Mark's
a year since the Russian invasion of
Ukraine began the conflict has cost tens
of thousands of lives reawaken fears of
a general perhaps even nuclear war in
Europe and created political and
economic instability that has been felt
right around the world well we've been
asking for your questions all day about
the war what's happening on the ground
what will happen next how might it all
end and throughout this hour we're going
to be putting some of them there have
been many many of them to our defense
and security analyst Professor Michael
Clarke very good evening to you Michael
once again and before we get into those
questions just a quick thought Michael
on the first anniversary of the war
which of course originally Putin thought
would be the first anniversary more or
less of him taking Ukraine and Kiev
absolutely yeah three days to take
Ukraine get rid of the zielinski kill
him get rid of the government all over
by about March the 8th where they'd be
in control of the big cities and then
just sitting on the on Ukraine as a a
new constitutional arrangement for
Russia the world changed this time a
year ago Europe certainly changed and
I've always said there's no hiding from
this there's no turning back this is a
new security situation we've got to live
with it it'll be risky and there's
there's nothing we can do to pretend we
can go back to where we were well uh
let's look to the Future and not
necessarily an enticing Outlook through
the questions and dig straight into them
so Michael uh deal with this one from
Nick first of all to kick us off could
Russia attack Ukraine with new weapons
systems on the first anniversary of the
start of the war now these are the
weapon systems that Putin Clancy has and
wanted to test didn't he on the the day
that Biden was in here yeah he was
talking about the is Hypersonic missiles
that he was talking about today the
Zircon uh anti-ship missile and they've
got to the kinzal air launched
Hypersonic missile they won't uh I don't
think what I think they may do is launch
the 15th Big Air offense so they've been
14 waves where they've launched more
than a thousand missiles and drones to
really hit the infrastructure they might
do that again in the next 24 48 Hours my
guess will be they would I've got no
information that they will but I won't
be surprised if they do new weapons are
not they're something that Putin
pretends he's got lots of in order to
frighten the West that the war is
getting worse and worse but actually
he's doing his worst as it is until this
new offensive begins this offensive
which I think hasn't really started so
he's saying he doesn't actually have
them I mean we you know towards the end
of the second world war with with the
Nazis it was Wonder Weapons wasn't it
yeah that would say the v1s the V2s
exactly if they'd arrived earlier they'd
made a difference to the war but they
didn't thankfully as well as nuclear
weapons which the Germans were working
on
um however I mean what the Russians have
got they've got these systems which are
relevant to a U.S Russia global war
which would be used in all that nuclear
exchange or something like that but
we're not remotely near that at the
moment he pretends that we're going down
that road we're not okay well Brian and
asks the follow-up question very nicely
for us Brian says what can we expect
then from the long-awaited Russian
offensive and that is expected some say
it's kind of building up now yeah I mean
I don't think the offensive has started
yet some people say it has and if this
is the offensive then it's not very good
I mean they're not they're not achieving
very much
um what I think they will try to do is
take the whole of the donbass and that
is plausible from their point of view if
it goes really well for the Russians I
think they'll take the donbass they'll
strengthen the land bridge from the
donbass to
Crimea and then West again to Herson and
maybe go for a death or a second time if
it went well if it went really really
well they might then try to push North
from zapparizia up the nipra river in
order to split Ukraine into a third two
thirds into one-third to the east
two-thirds of the West that was a
plausible strategic objective when we
thought the Russians might be be capable
of doing something like that a year ago
but that would be the very best that
they could hope for in this offense okay
we'll take that on board you've yeah
painted some of the possibilities there
and Dan asks this really asking you to
focus then well where do you think given
their resources mixed with their
Ambitions the next big Russian push will
be where logically it has to be in the
dombas because that's what they want
that's Putin's minimal requirement he
said we're only he's changed his War
aims all the time but the last set of
War aims he came up with is that we have
to protect the Russian speakers and the
donbass ETC et cetera so they want to
take all the donbass when this offensive
really starts I suspect we'll see it in
four or five areas because they'll want
to try to stretch the ukrainians by
giving them something to worry about
near Kiev maybe going towards again
maybe even moving westwards toward live
these will be you know operations
intended in a sense to give the
Ukrainian something else to bother about
but what they really want is the that
area that you see the shading there at
sort of three o'clock on the clock if
you see think of Ukraine as a sort of an
oval clock there at three o'clock that's
the donbass and they if they can take
the whole of the donbassador draw a line
in your mindful kharkiv write down to if
you like person down in the southwest if
they could take that then Putin would
say well yeah I've protected the Russian
speakers
um that's that's a big ask even so but I
think when this offensive starts I think
we'll see it in several places because
they'll want to try to split Ukrainian
forces and so is that why let's look in
the middle of that uh donbass region
they're back mode yeah is that why the
fighting there has been so Fierce and
taken something you you and asks how
important is back moot for the Russians
the answer is not very
um I mean that must been the focus for
the last uh three months by the wardner
group this is the private military
company that run by pragos in and they
progressions at war with the with the
the Kremlin he's at war with grazimov
um and he's at war with sugar the
defense minister and prigozin is trying
to prove that only he and the Wagner
group can do something where's the the
Russian military have been failing
everywhere else in the theater but he
the Wagner group can take back but they
thought they'd take it easily even today
he was publicly publicly arguing on
telegram that he said they're keeping a
short of artillery they're deliberately
they the Russian military are
deliberately keeping us short of
artillery so we can't take back look
it's become a personal Crusade of his to
take this place but what kind of
Manpower is he spending well here of
hearing of horrendous losses yeah well
they they had about 10 000
um Wagner mercenaries in theater theater
and those are all ex-soldiers who knew
what they were doing they were very
brutal people but they had up to another
40 000 some said fifty thousand convicts
that they were that they'd recruited
from the prisons and they've been dying
in very high numbers because they're put
in the front line I mean the deal that
pragos in gave them and we've got we've
got testimony of him doing this we've
got pizzas for filming doing this he
gets everybody together in these prisons
he has done and he said it's like
something out of the dirt he doesn't
literally he said only God will get you
out of this prison but I can get you out
today if you sign up you'll get good
food you get training and we will put
you on the front line if you disobey an
order or if you withdraw we'll shoot you
straight off out of hand if you're still
alive at the end of six months you're
free now that's what he said they
recruited 40 000 prisoners that way but
a they were getting shot in in for all
sorts of reasons and B they didn't keep
to their end of the bargain because at
the end of six months a lot of them were
made to sign on again or they just kept
there and so this this they're not now
recruiting for the prisons because
nobody actually wants nobody the prisons
don't want to go and on the issue of
backward Paul asks could Ukraine
encircle back by retreating and then
launching a counter-attack from the
North and the South and might have to
have a look at the map yeah it's not at
the moment but um Paul is on to
something there because when when the
ukrainians are able to get their act
together with the the equipment that
they're getting from the west and their
reorganization
um they we will see a war of maneuver
this hasn't been a war of maneuver so
far the Russians are not very good at
maneuvering they're moving in big
numbers and they gradually go forward
um the ukrainians too have been fairly
static they've been a lot cleverer than
the Russians but they haven't had the
equipment to maneuver as and when they
get these Western tanks operational and
that will be some time and organized for
it if they can put together two really
good armored brigades which means 100
tanks in each Brigade say then we'll see
some arrows on the map going quite
quickly and so what Paul was saying is
that can you can the Ukraine do it now
no they can't could they do it in two or
three months time maybe maybe because
okay when the ukrainians get moving
we'll see them move fast if they're able
to use this Western Equipment in the way
that it is intended and just um we
haven't got them on the map there you
can tell us where they are oh Michael
Tim asks why a crime a torsk and
slovians if you go westwards from bakmud
so if you go around about see the m in
back much if you sort of put you put a
couple of blobs on there North and South
um that is the the northern one of
slaviansk and the southern one is
crematorsk and those are both important
because if the Russians get slavians and
chromatos then they'll get the rest of
the donbass because they get the
railings particularly from chromatosk
but ukrainians have made slavian
synchromatowski into fortresses they're
on high ground there's there's quite far
there's a lot of water between bakmut
and slavery ants because it's very
watery area there and so if the even if
the Russians get back milk which they
may they I think they've almost
encircled it and I think the ukrainians
will probably have to withdraw getting
that relatively short distance from from
uh back to slavian's comators will be
tough and the ukrainians will make it
very tough for them so a big an even
bigger battle would come if the Russians
are able to do that well Alexander our
next questionnaire asks something
following on from that if the Russian
offensive fails badly as you're saying
is a possibility there and the Western
Harvard Vehicles arrive would the
ukrainians have the capacity to retake
their territory what difference would
those tanks in particular make huge
difference yeah so the answer is yes
they certainly will and certainly what
they intend to do and as I say if we if
we go back to
um maneuver if if we're going to see him
a war of maneuver now that the
ukrainians are able to use and the
Russians are very poor at Maneuvers so
far then we'll see quite a lot of
changes to that map that map hasn't
changed very much in months when you
just look at it we've been putting up
the same map as kite news and talking
about little bits of it around the edges
if the ukrainians can get their act
together by April or May we'll start to
see that map change yes they can retake
territory how much territory will depend
okay well Weaponry crucial there as
you're mentioning Michael so let's talk
about Weaponry now and how it affects
our own Security in the UK and the West
Whitehall sources of Tel Sky News that
the UK is reviewing the size of its
ammunition stockpiles because Russia's
invasion of Ukraine has shown them to be
far too small our security and defense
editor Deborah Haynes reports
Western weapons
in eastern Ukraine
they're evening up the battlefield for
Ukrainian troops against Russia's much
larger Army
but neither side stocks a finite
and a race is on to see who can re-arm
fastest
on Ukraine's front line near the city of
bakmut a soldier explains how this
makeshift cover protects his gun from
Russian suicide drones
he also talks about the need to preserve
ammunition
um
yet the rate of artillery fire over the
past year has been greater than at any
time since the Korean War
a Ukrainian officer has told Sky News
that Russia had been firing 60 000 to 70
000 shells a day a level that's about
halved as supplies run down
U.S officials have put that top rate at
around 20 000 a day but also say it's
dropped
Ukraine by contrast has been firing five
thousand to six thousand rounds daily
as for the impact Russia has lost around
9 000 pieces of military equipment such
as armored vehicles and artillery three
times more than Ukraine
with its tanks missiles and generosity
the UK is one of the Ukrainian
military's most important suppliers
but for how long I've been told Britain
is reviewing the size of its ammunition
stockpiles because Russia's Invasion
here has exposed how past assumptions on
what would be needed to fight a war were
far too conservative my sources say
Rishi sunak must increase defense
spending to fund a massive expansion in
ammunition and weapon stores or risk
being unable to keep supporting Ukraine
at the level needed
rebuilding the UK's military strength
after Decades of cuts is also critical
the Prime Minister talked tough when he
hosted Vladimir zelensky this month
but one Whitehall Source accused Mr
sunac of having no interest in defense
and security those charged with that in
number 10 can barely get access to him
the president zielinski visit was
engaged with late and with only
peripheral passing interest if it's not
domestic or economic it doesn't feature
a Second Source said he's a financier
and simply can't understand these things
a government spokesperson said these
claims are baseless and untrue it was
the Prime Minister who as Chancellor
agreed the 2020 spending review that
provided the ministry of Defense with
the largest increase in defense
investment since the Cold War
the prime minister is clear that we will
do everything necessary to protect our
people which is why our Armed Forces
will always have the equipment and
capability they need
of course the UK is only one of many
countries arming Ukraine that dwindling
stockpiles is a common theme that needs
fixing so the troops can keep firing
debraham Sky News Kiev
well my colleague Mark Austin earlier
asked the former prime minister Boris
Johnson about what difference greater
Western support could make to Ukraine
do not underestimate what the ukrainians
can do they they kicked him out of uh
the Kiev area where you are now they
kicked him out of the cocky area they
kicked him out of her son uh if they
have the right kit so if they have the
Deep fires the long range artillery if
they have enough tanks we need to give
them more tanks and yes if they have
planes to take out those those Russian
Artillery positions their Russian
Commander control as well then I've got
no doubt that President zolenski's armed
forces can recapture their territory
former prime minister Boris Johnson
there and his view no doubt that uh
Western Weaponry will continue to make a
difference to Ukraine and have got
Professor Michael Clarke here with me as
you know answering your questions about
all that and uh tanari asks this one
Michael will this new supplement of
Western weapons make a difference and
how quickly does it need to arrive and
can I add in you know what what does it
need to be we talked about tanks
aircraft on the list but as the former
prime minister Mr Johnson was saying
that as well the long-range artillery
yeah I mean it's it's everything really
I mean tanks themselves are of a
centerpiece but you've got to have
enough armored fighting vehicles to go
to go with them
um and armored infantry vehicles and
artillery that can move because it's all
going to move together it's combined
arms this is what the Russians are so
hopeless at doing it though they talk it
but they don't do it the ukrainians are
doing it but if they can do it with our
equipment they'll do it as well as a
NATO Army would do it which is to bring
tanks armored vehicles infantry
artillery and air power altogether into
one big arrow on the map that moves
maneuver Warfare again that really put
and we put that together it cut through
pretty well anything the Russians have
got now can they do it well we have to
have the training to do that as well
that's the point are they getting it
they are but it takes time and they
learn quick for sure and they are
learning quickly but also they've got to
reorganize themselves I mean fighting a
defensive War as they have done Dynamic
defense did really well that's quite
different to fighting an offensive
offensive War you've got to organize
differently think differently you've got
to actually have a different command and
control system so are they are they
capable of doing all that yes
um the danger for them is that they go a
little bit early before they're fully
formed into armored brigades that can
make a difference and they squander it
um and there may be a temptation to use
some of this stuff in defense if they if
the Russians start to push them hard in
the donbass in zapparesia they might
find they're deploying bits of this
stuff this these equipments and new
organizations at lower levels just to
hold the Russians back that that would
be a shame if they have to do that and
I'm sure at the moment they're trying to
they're playing for time the the
Ukraine's are on the defensive now in
the donbass in the last three or four
weeks and they're buying time and they
are literally as soldiers sometimes do
they're giving their lives to buy time
so that people elsewhere are training
for the offensive which they confidently
believe they'll be able to launch
sometime in later spring early summer
sounds pretty finely balanced Richard's
got a question specifically again about
tanks and I suppose you know one one
thought perhaps 10 15 years ago that
kind of Tanks had had their day and
Richard asks why have tanks continued to
play a significant role in the conflict
given the degree of long-range artillery
and air power can't they be picked off
no I once said years ago to a British
Cavalry officer and said how are you
getting getting on with the idea of the
passing of the tank and he said oh for
God's sake don't say that we're still
getting over the passing of the horse
which in the British Cavalry was sort of
true how however no tanks are a way of
creating mobility and Firepower so the
tank Carries a Gun and and other machine
guns it's it's protected and it's mobile
now by itself it can be very vulnerable
particularly to air power but if it's if
it's accompanied by things that can
protect it then it's still the best way
of of of punching holes in any defense
on the battlefield and the modern tank
The Leopard 2 or the Challenger 2 or the
American Abrams is still doing the basic
job that first world war tanks did first
on the psalm in 1916 and then in
Canberra in 1917 they were great
tractors with big guns on the side of
them and they were crude and they broke
down but it's the same job that they do
but these days they're part of a
sophisticated combined arms operation
and the tank is not passing at all but
it's changing and the things that need
to go with the tank are changing and the
roles that tanks can play is changing
but you know any anyone who thinks that
you can get by without tanks in any a
normal traditional sort of warfare is
going to be very rudely interrupted and
what about ammunition not just for tanks
but in particular for the big guns as
well Gary asks how much will Ukraine's
lack of access to plentiful artillery
shells how will that affect the outcome
of the war is this is one of the crucial
elements yeah they've been they use they
inherited all this 122 millimeter Soviet
stuff Russian stuff as well and they've
used a lot of that as they've been
getting more Western systems Western
artillery Western systems are 155
artillery shells a little bit bigger
that's the that's the base that's the
circumference sorry the diameter of the
base of the shell
um and they're restocking with 155
artillery
um potentially there's quite a lot of it
around of course but the The Americans
on their behalf are scouring the world
for one two two millimeter stuff that
countries have got from the old Soviet
Union they've still got because
artillery shells if they've been
properly stored they're okay for 30 or
40 years if they've been properly stored
but increasingly the the ukrainians need
the 155 NATO standard artillery because
those are the sort of artillery guns
that they're being given and and using
and for sure I mean there's millions of
artillery shells around in the world but
they are using them up faster than they
are being produced and the Americans
have just put in an order for their own
artery they've increased their normal
annual order by four times four-fold
increase in the next five years because
they've realized that you need an awful
lot more artillery than you thought you
did even two years and that's the
question that how much is left for those
Nations that are donating those that's
right and our nations are falling we now
unprotected ourselves for sure yeah for
sure and Ben Wallace the the mod has put
money aside for war stocks just for
artillery because we've we've given the
ukrainians quite a lot of what we've got
and we've we've got very little
ourselves and so it's more important
that Ukraine gets it at the moment for
sure
um but uh we've all got to restock and
and one of the arguments that we know
that Ben Wallace of We Believe I should
say Ben Wallace is having the Downing
Street is that our war stocks are so low
that our forces are not credible our
allies and our adversaries they know
that our forces look really good on
paper they've got the best equipment the
best troops the best training if you're
out of ammunition in a week which we
would if we were fighting for Ukraine
goodness then you lose yeah and if we
were fighting that the intensity of the
ukraines are fighting we would run out
of ammunition in about a week so however
Brave you are however well trained you
are you lose
what about the really high-tech stuff we
heard president zielinski didn't we not
very far away from here uh asking
directly for aircraft for fighter jets
and Scott asks if we Supply Jets to
Ukraine do they have the pilots to fly
them and how long would it take to train
them on these unfamiliar aircraft it's
it's not just about the kit is it
expertise to use it depends on the
pilots of course I mean Ukrainian pilots
who have got combat experience on their
own mig-29s the RAF estimates privately
that they could train those up onto a
modern aircraft into our modern IR
aircraft if it if we were to give them
our aircraft or American aircraft or
Swedish grip-ins are probably the best
they could do it in probably a month or
six weeks if it was a pilot without
combat experience you might be talking
about a couple of months or three months
if it's somebody you've got to train to
be a pilot I mean we spend three years
training pilots and we don't train
nearly enough you could probably do it
in a year because you know the
ukrainians learn faster got an incentive
to squeeze the whole training program in
and work 18 hours a day if they need to
so yes we could train up Ukrainian
pilots and Britain's committee to do
that I mean we haven't got any aircraft
to give to be in all honesty we would
have to give the whole of the Air Force
such as it now is we've got seven we've
got seven flash jet Squad and seven you
know in the Gulf War in 1991 we had 19
squadrons now we've got seven so we we
could give them the whole Air Force he
still wouldn't be enough
um so we've got no aircraft to give in
in reality and Michael what about I mean
we're talking personnel there and
training it's not of course just the
pilots you know okay they're responsible
when it's in the air but it's getting it
into the air and keeping it able to fly
what about the ground Crews the training
they require and of course where would
they be positioned if they're supplied
by the UK by NATO country really good
point because Western aircraft are very
complex so they need quite a complex
ground crew and therefore you need you
need to concentrate resources these very
Technical Resources in one or two bases
but if you're in a war you've got to
have a number of bases you've got to
spread your Air Force out so it's not
easily targetable so you need lots of
backup and support spread across a big
area we don't do that because in NATO
over the last 40 years we've
concentrated concentrated concentrated
for efficiency which it is more
efficient in peace time on some big
bases with some real Specialists but you
know you need a lot more than that so
giving aircraft to Ukraine requires
giving them air support which is a whole
lot of things a bit like tanks but even
more complex than just the aircraft okay
Michael well one of the reasons that
some countries have been hesitant about
giving Ukraine tanks and fighter jets
and the rest is of course because they
feel the risk of escalation how Russia
might react to that well let's talk
about it all now because it's an issue
that was put to Boris Johnson by Mark
Austin earlier
what are the consequences though of
failure in your view
I think the consequences of any kind of
Putin Victory any kind of uh there was
there's a couple of things first of all
he's able to continue to uh threaten not
just Ukraine but Georgia Moldova the
Baltic states Poland anywhere on the
vast periphery of the former Soviet
Empire don't forget this is what this is
all about he was never really threatened
by Ukraine as a potential NATO member
there was no question of establishing uh
NATO missiles on Ukrainian soil any of
that nonsense this has purely been done
by Putin to bolster his flagging
position at home and to try to
reconstitute uh the old Soviet Empire
Mr Johnson there with his analysis of
Russian Ambitions and Borges asks uh
this uh Jonathan mentioning Belarus to
the north of Ukraine and a loyal Russian
Ally he asks if Belarus enters the war
will other European countries join in as
well
um in response I mean this is all about
NATO getting drawn in yeah I mean no I'm
sure is the answer I think it's very
unlikely that Belarus will enter the war
in any significant way uh president
lukashenko in Belarus is um his own
position is not great in terms of his
domestic support
the war is very unpopular in Belarus and
the belarusians really don't want to get
engaged their army is extremely small
they claim to have an army of fifty
thousand nobody believes that they could
probably put 15 000 into the field and
not very well trained not very well
equipped but Belarus can because it's
got a long border with uh Ukraine their
border is useful to Russia and Russia
has sent Russian troops into Belarus to
pose the possibility that they might
cross the border again and start to go
for Kiev as it happens there are some
Belarusian troops fighting in Ukraine
there's about two battalions fighting
for the ukrainians Belarusian volunteers
and they fight for the other side so no
I mean Belarus is not a serious it's a
complication but it's not a serious
military threat and if Belarus was
foolish enough to enter the war and I
think lukashenko will be lucky to
survive if he did but if he you know if
if they did other other states would
just take it on the chin they just they
wouldn't react it wouldn't invade
because of it you kind of asked the next
question from Rich which is uh again
about Belarus is it going to be the next
excuse to expand Putin's efforts under
the guise of a threat to Belarus by the
ukrainians well it kind of already is on
there yeah control isn't it there is
there is a report moving around which
we're not sure if it's genuine but
there's no reason why it won't be
genuine which is a a Russian strategic
position paper on Putin's desire to take
over Belarus by 2030. now that may not
turn out to be genuine but if it isn't
genuine it ought to be because it's
exactly what he wants to do I mean he
wants to recreate the old Russian Empire
of Peter the Great and Catherine the
Great and there's no argument about it
he said it on many occasions and
Ukraine's Central to that absolutely
Ukrainian Central and so is Belarus I
mean Belarus was the old belarusia it's
white Russia as was so the idea that
Putin has it in mind that to manipulate
events so that by 2030 he takes over
Belarus into a new sort of the Russian
Federation is entirely plausible
um whether the report that's kicking
around now is genuinely not I don't know
um but yes it that's quite quite likely
in his mind okay and uh Michael
moldova's very interesting in all this
in terms of expansion Chris asks is
there a danger of Moldova being
destabilized by Russia no that was the
that was the richest question we moved
on to Chris's it doesn't matter and
we'll get the map back up and just show
everyone where Moldova is Moldova
sandwiched between Romania and Ukraine
it has it's landlocked and transnistria
that region is very important within me
that's right yeah what was the smaller
stating you're very weak it's very small
very weak uh there it is I mean between
Ukraine and Romania traditionally part
of Romania
um it's it has in it transnistria which
is the nistra river which runs through
it down to the Black Sea and the area of
transnistria includes a an enclave of
russian-speaking nationalists it's it's
actually the base of the old 14th Army
the Red Army 14th Army used to be in
Moldova and a lot of retired officers
are there with their families and so on
and so this country of uh what three and
a half four million people has got about
half a million who are transnistrians
who demand or require or ask for Unity
with Russia
um used to be it used to be called best
Arabia I'm recalling my old a-level
history now Bess Arabia is part of
Romania however I mean Moldova itself
um there was an attempt last weekend at
a coup in effect on Sunday last week the
Russian minority called a demonstration
to complain about the government because
as it happens the transmission area
provides all the power for the rest of
Moldova just because because they're on
the river they actually have a lot of
Russian Aid I mean a lot of Russian
stuff goes into it though and they tried
to create a demonstration to remove the
government which is a very pro-western
government led by a very pro-western
prime minister and president
um and it failed it was a pretty
miserable demonstration but clearly it
was inspired by Moscow it was aided by
Moscow they thought they'd get you know
100 000 people on the street they seem
to get about ten thousand at most okay
got to take a break now Michael thank
you for that so far you're watching Sky
News Tonight a special question and
answer session on Ukraine with Professor
Michael Clarke now coming up in this
we'll address the most common question
that everyone's been sending in the big
question will this all end in World War
III let's stay with us
thank you
the Press preview a first look at the
front pages as they arrive there's a
feeling among some commentators that
it's not the most respectful timing I
think there's a word for it fake news I
mean it's
delving deeper into the stories with
different perspectives on tomorrow's
headlines we really haven't seen the
government getting around the table and
negotiating there are no easy answers to
those questions the Press preview
delivering you tomorrow's news tonight
on Sky News
[Music]
[Applause]
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
oh
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power you must stay at home and it's my
job to figure out how these decisions
made by politicians impact all of us in
our everyday lives this is the worst
thing I've ever been through in my life
people turn up here with their child
stuff in a black sack and just say I
don't want to and that is what it is
it's first class profit is this an
example of the welfare state failing we
take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world these are stories
that affect us all
billions of children are now having to
catch up some stories have changed all
of our Lives because like the residents
the staff are being infected politicians
they make decisions all of the time and
it's our job to hold them to account I
wonder if you will take this opportunity
to apologize to those families but in
the end the real power doesn't actually
lie with the politicians
real power lies with the people
I'm Nick Martin I'm the people and
politics correspondent at Sky News
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back we're answering your
questions about the war in Ukraine as we
approach exactly one year since the
Russian invasion began Professor Michael
Clarke is still here with me answering
those questions so we're going to turn
now to the issue and the role of China
now earlier Mark Austin asked the former
prime minister Boris Johnson for his
views about a possible Chinese
intervention
what would the consequences be do you
think if China
actively supported Russia in this war by
supplying Weaponry I think it would be a
historic Mistake by the by the Chinese I
was very concerned to see what Wong Yi
was uh was doing yesterday uh in in
Moscow I I think you know it would be a
big mistake why does China want to be
contaminated by association with with
Putin who's revealed himself to be this
gangster and adventurer I think it would
be a big mistake by by China but what it
what it shows is the the urgency of us
giving the ukrainians what they need to
succeed this year
well Boris Johnson's saying that any
Chinese intervention would be a historic
mistake and uh Brian has sent in a
question asking that's very question
what can we expect China's next move to
be in the conflict they appear to be
giving mixed signals and Michael this is
because they're also talking about a
peace plan as well at the same time and
it's the Americans that have been saying
they have evidence that they think China
is going to be handing over weapons Xi
Jinping is due to make a speech tomorrow
uh if it's not postponed if not tomorrow
then probably Saturday and it's called
the peace speech but I suspect we'll see
it tomorrow or hear it tomorrow and
there is a peace plan which the Chinese
intend to launch Wang Yi who is a
prominent Diplomat is not foreign
spokesperson for the Chinese he's been
in Moscow this week and this peace plan
uh we'll see what it it involves I don't
think it'll involve anything very
surprising but um Brian is exactly right
the Chinese algorithmic signals and it's
interesting that Wang Yi when he was in
Moscow he didn't use the phrase that
xujinping had used he didn't say that
this is a partnership Without Limits
that was this phrase that was picked up
he said the the Chinese Russian
partnership is Without Limits you would
have Without Limits came from a year ago
didn't it went well yeah that's right
before this started and wagy did not did
not repeat that and that was an
interesting Omission so he talked about
a very strong partnership I mean there
is a there is a strong relationship
between China and Russia because they're
both revisionist Powers they both want
to change the rules of the International
System for their own different reasons
they're the two great revisionist powers
in the world that gives them a
combination because we have talked about
this before but they're not equal Powers
you know is Russia in danger of becoming
a client of China if they if they do
accept any substantial Aid Russia's
Russia is moving into the position of
being like North Korea like like a
bigger problem but a version of North
Korea I mean just one indication I mean
Russia is now selling its oil to China
because it has to it can't sell it to to
the Western world it's selling it at
forty dollars a barrel which is about
half the global price it's how it's it's
on its knees in front of China at the
moment because it needs it and China's
trade with Russia is about three percent
of its total trade I mean most of
China's trade is with Europe and North
America
um you know it's trade with with Russia
is Tiny and so Xi Jinping he genuinely
likes Putin and Xi Jinping you know sees
a commitment and he sees the the the
need to uphold a front against America
against the Western world but this the
war is doing China no good and the
prospect of of Russia becoming a sort of
a big version of North Korea really
worries the China so they make are the
Chinese making a judgment then about
what Russia can achieve let's ask the
next question because that kind of
encapsulated as well uh it's from John
he says How likely is an ad vagina to
become directly involved in the conflict
and what support would they provide well
first and foremost arms and weapons
that's what the Russians want I mean the
Chinese we've got vast stocks of
ammunition that we were talking about
the artillery shells but they've also
got Precision weapons Precision missiles
which the Russians are running out of if
the Chinese were prepared to open their
Arsenal to the Russians then the
Russians will not lose that's the point
the Chinese could stop the Russians from
losing it but the price to China will be
very high indeed because the Americans
have made it really clear to China and
you know if you do this a we might
Supply a lot more weapons that you'd
prefer we didn't but secondly there will
be secondary sanctions in other words we
will sanction your companies the Chinese
are really frightened of American
sanctions they've seen Western sanctions
and they couldn't believe how powerful
they have turned out to be we've been
surprised by how powerful they've been
and they're really frightened of
American sanctions being slapped on
Chinese companies all over the world but
it's also getting very geopolitical as
well as another of the Chinese judgments
about whether it hands over weapons and
and ammunition their Ambitions towards
Taiwan they're seeing what it takes the
the Russian effort in Ukraine which is
not half as well as the Taiwanese are
and they some American generals are
saying they might have a go the Chinese
might have a go within the next two
years they need an awful lot of arms for
that they might but they've got 100 100
miles of water to cross not just not
just a couple of rivers but if the if
the Chinese try to solve their Taiwan
Problem by force I'm pretty sure it
won't be a an invasion that suddenly
starts one day almost certainly it would
be a sort of series of political
um initiatives which creates effectively
a blockade of Taiwan which gets Tighter
and Tighter and Tighter and that would
put the onus on the west you know when
do you react when do you actually start
to try to break this blockade so it
would start with a trade issue then it
would be
intercepting uh ships in the open sea or
in in an area that the Chinese claim is
their territory which it won't be but
they would claim it and so it would be a
sort of tightening noose to see how far
they could push it before the West
responded so it wouldn't be built from
the blue attack I'm I'm fairly confident
but it would be a military response
which gets more and more serious uh
which would pose the dilemmas for the
Western just underline that point you
made earlier you just touched on it
Michael Klein asks this one what would
be the impact of China sending arms to
Russia I mean it made the hairs on the
back of my next stand on end you think
that you know if China went all in in
support of Russia it would be over in
Russia's favor well they could stop the
Russians losing on the battlefield so
they could mean that the the Russians
could Prevail given that the Russians
are prepared to throw any numbers at
this in terms of people that prepared
for any set of casualties if they had
unlimited uh Precision missiles and
unlimited artillery then the chances are
they would they could conquer the air as
they wanted to conquer and then the
Russians would have just left themselves
with a small problem of a guerrilla War
for the next 50 years in the country of
44 million people this is the point
you've made before that if you conquer a
country that isn't welcoming you as they
thought it a year ago well it's all very
well winning a few battles but then you
try and actually control that exactly
and your choices then is live with the
Guerrilla war and hope that you can keep
it down down to levels that you can live
with or suppress the country so much
that you create a complete reign of
terror and again A Reign of Terror in a
country of 44 million people on the
doorstep of Europe surrounded by
friendly countries apart from Russia and
Belarus will be very difficult to do
I've always wanted to ask that though
Michael I mean there's quite a lot of
territory the Russians have taken and
hold and you know we've seen them trying
to transform cities like mariupo is
there any of that Guerrilla activity
taking place right now okay have we got
any evidence of that but behind
so-called enemy love of gorilla gorilla
oh yeah yes there is some yeah um
partisan Warfare it went on in person
um when the Russians had cursed and
before they withdrew there was quite a
lot of it there there was a huge clamp
down a lot of people were just taken
away during the night there's a lot of
Terror and those attacks ceased for a
while but there's been they've been
springing up again not in now in cursing
because that's back in Ukrainian hands
but Melita pole there's lots of reports
under Russian control at the moment
there's there's lots of reports of of
partisan activity but so far not so much
of it that the Russians have got a big
problem but the Ross vardia is there
this is their Home Defense Force there's
400 000 Ross vardia numbers the rods
vardia you know internal troops they're
bigger than the Army uh the Army was
only 280 000.
directly responsible to Putin himself
only he is the commander 400 000 and
they've got Ross vardia there who are
the Gestapo of the place and they've got
them there in very high numbers and
they're as I say in certain areas
they've created a dark gestapo night on
some of these cities okay we're going to
talk now about uh the risk of contagion
of a World War developing out of this
and earlier today we heard from the
Ukrainian prime minister
if we assume that Ukraine could lose
this war it will be an extremely
powerful signal for Russia and for any
aggressor that it is possible to do this
in the Civilized world and it will
potentially cause many wars and possibly
World War III
yeah we had from the Ukrainian prime
minister possibly world war three let's
um put our next question on that to
Professor Michael Clarke an anonymous
contributor asking in a war where
neither side seems to be genuinely
looking for peace are there any
mechanisms actually in place for
stopping this escalating into something
truly Global uh what are your thoughts
yes uh there are I mean the chances of
World War III are very very remote
um because world wars are created and
they've been created twice in the 20th
century when big Empires
um have Global interests and pursue
those interests all over the globe and
so they Clash everywhere and that's what
first world war second world war became
and the second world war was actually a
series of four or five different Wars
that all coalesced into what we
collectively called the second world war
um you you can't create a scenario in
which that genuinely happens there's
loads of novels out there on the station
bookstores which which have World War
III titles and I've read quite a lot of
them they it's it's the connections
between the conflicts that they're never
convincing with they can give you a an
outline of a conflict in the Middle East
a conflict in southern Africa or
conflict in Europe they never link up in
the way that they did link up in the
20th century now the mechanisms that you
know I mean Mark Malik Brown today uh
great United Nations uh uh official
retired um he was saying it's it's sad
that the un can't do more and that's
true but the fact is that the mechanisms
for stopping it escalating in a sense is
the balance of power it's the big
countries that know that that this war
has got somehow to be fought through but
it has also got to be somehow contained
um and it's not in their interest to let
it go anywhere else and certainly you
know Latin America Africa Central Asia
they don't want anything to do with it
um the outcome of the war is terribly
important to the world but there's a
determination that this is not about
anything else than the the conflict in
Europe between an autocratic State and
the liberal democracies want to help it
but could something be sparked let's put
our next question by by a scenario that
Joe puts for us um is
there it is is American and UK
involvement in the conflict pushing us
closer to a World War how much more help
can we provide before Putin takes it as
a direct attack on Russia and this has
been the case since the start of this
conflict this calculation taking place
in Western capitals yeah well you know
if we send this or that Armament to
Ukraine how will that be interpreted by
Russia we seem to be moving beyond that
point but if it progresses further and
we talk for instance even about uh
support ground Crews something like that
not necessarily combat forces is there a
danger that we end up with NATO and
Russia actually coming into contact with
each other that's the big red line that
both sides recognize at the moment and
the Russians are behaving despite what
they say and they come up with scare
stories every day to try and frighten us
into pushing the ukrainians to stop
um but they the Russians recognize the
red line and we recognize the red line I
don't know quite why we all make such
hard work of this because it seems like
fairly simple we can give the ukrainians
whatever weapons they need to Prevail on
the battlefield because they're just
trying to win back their territory
everything they do with whatever systems
is defensive because they're trying to
win back their territory and all we've
got to do is to say to the ukrainians
you have to promise us that you won't
use these long-range missiles to attack
Russian territory directly and the
ukrainians will give that promise and we
can believe it 100 for one obvious
reason that if the Ukraine is starting
to attack Russia directly then they
would lose the support of the West and
they'd lose the war the most suicidal
thing the ukrainians could do would be
to take our long-range weapons and use
them to attack Russia okay that loses
them the war so I'm completely relaxed
about the fact that they won't do it
okay well I'm going to roll our next two
questions together because you've kind
of answered Mike's one which asks is it
inevitable that this will become a
full-scale war involving NATO you think
not but Martin asks what would a
conventional war between Russia and NATO
look like and how safe would the UK be
we've talked on these programs us before
about a nuclear contact we may touch on
that a little later on in this session
but a conventional War I mean could it
happen and you know what form would it
take I mean presumably as you describe
NATO tactics which we're trying to teach
to the ukrainians if NATO itself was
employing them yeah NATO would win yeah
and NATO on paper NATO is immensely
stronger than Russia immensely stronger
in terms of numbers Manpower Air Forces
everything now NATO has been sort of
hollowed out over the years I mean
there's been a sort of structural
disarmament going on throughout Western
Europe since the end of the Cold War and
so defense policies have become more and
more
um cheap and we haven't kept up with it
but in the last 10 years NATO since the
2016 Summit the Wales Summit if you
remember uh no 2014 Wales Summit
um there was a big sort of Clarion call
then and NATO has made big efforts NATO
countries made big efforts not so much
our own but other countries have made
big efforts to catch up on what they've
they've lost
um if there was if you played out a war
game a trivenham at our staff college
and say all right there's there's the
Russian team there's the NATO team what
happens and other things being equal
Russia wouldn't stand a chance
conventionally
well let's talk about uh
unconventionally and of course we're
thinking of nuclear weapons and the
possible use of nuclear weapons is cast
a shadow over this entire conflict
almost since it began in an address this
morning uh President Putin said that
mass deliveries of hypersonic missiles
we were discussing earlier are to be
made to Russia's Navy as it enters a new
state of battle readiness
as before we will pay increased
attention to strengthening the nuclear
Triad this year the first launchers of
the samat missile system with a new
heavy missile enter combat Duty we will
continue serial production of the kinzal
air launched Hypersonic systems and
begin Mass deliveries of zircon sea
launched Hypersonic missiles
President Putin there are talking about
his Hypersonic missiles as discussed
earlier with Professor Michael Clark and
Stu asks this Michael do you see the
possibility of a decisive victory for
Ukraine where Russia accepts defeat
without the use of nuclear weapons as a
last resort and this has always been the
worry isn't it that if you if you defeat
Russia on the battlefield well then they
they won't take it lying down and
they'll use something tactical and
nuclear that's possible access portable
I don't think it's very I think it's
it's barely possible is what I would say
there's lots of other scenarios one is
that Putin is removed before this war is
over and that doesn't mean to say he'll
be replaced by anybody more peaceful
because the people around him think the
way he does but at least it would be
somebody different and I again I don't
have any problem talking about what the
the outcome would be and it could be
this if Ukraine was successful suppose
they could throw Russia out of all the
territories that they have conquered
since February and that's entirely
plausible if they can get their act
together this year let's pause them
um and we'd all we'd all say that was a
good result because then Putin's
Adventure will have failed possibly
they could throw Russia out of the
territories they took in 2014 in the
dombas and that leaves the issue of
Crimea
and what you do with Crimea it's very
simple you say this is a really
difficult issue you give it to an
international tribunal to look at to
adjudicate on the tribunal City for 40
years comes up with nothing doesn't
matter because it takes it off the front
line and the rest of us get on with our
lives in the meantime that's what you do
with international issues I mean it's
the same with northern northern Cyprus
unresolved so it goes to International
discussion and everybody gets on with
their lives so nobody has to give
anything so the ukrainians keep on
claiming it the Russians keep on saying
it's it's intrinsically Russia for
historical reasons which is not true in
international law but they have a they
have a historical argument and you argue
argue argue around with a tribunal that
meets once a month for 20 years
producers report everyone ignores it but
you've had 20 years break from worrying
about it and by then who knows the
situation may be different but I mean
isn't the danger in that scenario the
20-year break is where everyone re-arms
and then and a new population grows up
and you've got you know fresh troops to
put into another battle it is the case
that if this war ends as it were
victoriously for the ukrainians if they
get their territory back all but Ukraine
put on the Shelf
they would still have to live with the
idea that they will be a heavily armed
State because they're facing a Russia
which under present leadership and under
present thinking in Russia not just
Putin regards Ukraine as a non-state and
somewhere that ought to be conquered and
so I mean the ukrainians say this
themselves say we we will be the Israel
of Europe we'll be the heavily armed
state with a constant fear or constant
danger of being eliminated by a neighbor
now the difference with Israel in
Ukraine's case either wouldn't have a
Palestinian problem issue and B they're
not surrounded by hostile States they're
all state potentially hostile they are
surrounded by friends apart from Belarus
and Russia itself so but in one respect
yeah the Israel of Europe is not
unrealistic I mean the ukrainians are in
for a future of heavy Armament and
constant vigilance okay so that's a
point that might be reached but let's
end this session then with a question
that asks how might we get there it's
from Chris who asks I'm not sure we'll
be able to get it get it up there in
time so I'll just read it out beyond the
battlefield what diplomacy will be going
on directly between the major Powers I
mean you know we don't know anything in
terms of in terms of talks we've known
that you know turkey's got involved in
the past individuals they've got
involved Roman Abramovich are there any
contacts are there any back channels
between the major powers between the
United States Russia and China yeah you
bet there are yeah they're going on all
the time I mean I could I'm not going to
but I could name a couple of British
individuals who are involved I could
name individuals in the Gulf who were
involved and sometimes they work on edge
on the side issues I mean they've been
some prisoner exchanges that suddenly it
suddenly appears one day that yeah
exchange no build up to it it's all been
worked on generally speaking by the
international committee on the Red Cross
lots of things are happening uh Refugee
things are happening but people are
looking for areas in which they can have
an arrangement between the two sides
that suits them both in prisoner
exchanges are one of the areas that may
be the case so yes a lot of people all
in Europe and the wider world are trying
to to as well excite their contacts on
all sides and a lot of Russians are
doing this as well to say can we talk
about this can we talk about that the
the diplomacy will stay private until
such time as it can as it were coming to
the open as part of a bigger framework
but lots of people I promise you are
looking for whatever linkages they can
find because some linkages are better
than no linkages and is the point that
building up those relationships even if
you're not talking originally out about
ultimate peace yeah they're important
those are relationships the fact you are
talking even if it's about something as
call it mundane it's important of course
as a prisoner exchange though it's it's
about the technicalities you've got the
contact yeah and in the business it's
called track two diplomacy and sometimes
it's in the foreign office they talk
about track one and a half diplomacy
track one is official diplomacy that's
all written down and is available to the
Press afterwards and so on track two
diplomacy is stuff that goes on that you
just don't you don't talk to anyone else
about and track two diplomacy builds up
the atmosphere which can then become
track one so there is a lot of track two
diplomacy going on do you think it'll
bear fruit I mean Have You Got
Confidence we're talking about another
year now in terms of the conflict you
think something diplomatic could happen
before then yes it can bear fruit and
it's going on Via China as well remember
not just Russia and Europe
um yes it can bear fruit but not until
there's the the war takes a different
turn the the offensives which are
presently about to take place will play
themselves out they'll create some sort
of new situation on the ground and then
depending on what that situation is
there may be some sort of diplomacy
that's possible I'll tell you what could
be possible supposing the the Russians
are able to surround Kiev they will take
it but say they could surround it and
threaten Kiev and suppose in the
ukrainians are able to threaten Crimea
with their new offensive then both sides
might say okay let's talk because
there'd be a sort of a symmetry there
that might provide the base at least for
a ceasefire but I have to say before
that diplomatic framework would become
possible sadly there's a great deal of
dying to do yet
Michael has Everett's being fantastic
getting your expertise there thank you
very very much indeed for sharing so
much of it with us Professor Michael
Clark there coming up next much more on
the first anniversary of the attack on